you mentioned hrf
human rights foundation
what is it uh what is its mission
yeah so i've been working for href
since 2007
we are a charity a nonprofit a 501c3
based in new york and our mission is to
promote and protect individual rights
and freedoms in authoritarian societies
around the world so again we we define
about 95 countries as authoritarian
meaning it's either a one-party state or
opposition politicians are outlawed or
persecuted there's no real free speech
there's no press freedom there's no
independent judiciary there really
aren't checks and balances and even
trying to create like a human rights
organization uh or like an environmental
group uh would be illegal um and the
majority of the world's population lives
in that environment that's very
important you said 53.63 4.3 billion
people and i saw you outlined a lot of
different um
sources of suffering in the world
and then you sort of put people living
under authoritarian
governments as like more than all of
them
i i forget i forget all the examples you
provided but
sure i mean it's uh yeah maybe a
convention if you remember the number of
people who are refugees the number of
people who suffer from natural disasters
the number of people who live under
abject poverty the number of people who
don't have access to clean drinking
water all of these are dwarfed by the
number of people who live under
authoritarianism
and yet it's not something that we talk
about a lot because people are
mercantilist and the powers that be are
happy to sacrifice
freedoms and privacy for money we live
in a profit-seeking world
to get evidence of this take a look at
the list of sponsors of the upcoming
olympics in in china where the ccp is
currently committing genocide against
the weaker population or look at the
number of people and the famous
investors who went to saudi arabia a
couple months ago for the davos in the
desert i mean ray dalio was there all
kinds of people were there and or at
least they were invited and they said
they were going to go
and this is a government that
at the time was torturing a female
activist who just wanted to drive a car
this is a government that had murdered
jamal khashoggi uh in a brutal fashion
uh just a couple years earlier
so i mean at the end of the day when
when it comes down to brass tacks i mean
you know the powers that be the even the
free countries are led by people um who
are very very happy to sacrifice all
these pretty words about human rights
when it when it comes down to profits
unfortunately so do you think capitalism
that's maybe one of the flaws of
capitalism is it turns a blind eye to
injustices against human nature
against the human rights
like it turns a blind eye to
authoritarian governments
look i think that at the end of the day
like
free trade
is actually
really good um and you can just look at
france and germany as an example of how
like a capitalist structure would
develop if you have two capitalist
actors they're very unlikely to fight
each other there's very unlikely to be
violence right these are two countries
which
basically murdered
some large percentage of each other's
male population three times in a hundred
years in three different wars right and
now today war is like unthinkable and a
lot of that is because of increased
collaboration increased trade so when
you have two capitalist actors
they act
in a very productive way with each other
um but as soon as you introduce an
authoritarian actor you know all bets
are off so i think what you have is a
conflict between
capitalist actors and authoritarian
actors
and at the end of the day people
need to
yes have more than just capitalist
intentions
in in the geopolitical
level i'm talking about they need to
actually take a stand for principles
otherwise you have athletes and
businesses and governments that are all
too happy to to do business with the
chinese communist party for example
right now i think that there is a little
more than just kind of the pure
the pure profit yes
you